pour soi alors il paraît que pour bien
commencer une conférence ted
il faut commencer par une phrase du
genre imaginer un truc inspirant
imaginez un virus potentiellement
mortelles qui se propagerait super
facilement dans l'air les objets tous à
un virus qui mute ray tellement vite
qu'on ne trouverait pas de traitement
efficace ou de vaccin universel mais
surtout un virus tellement sournois que
personne ne s'en méfiera ça existe ça
s'appelle la grippe alors un virus comme
ça vous allez me dire c'est pas très
grave
moi je vous dirais un virus comme ça ça
peut ravager la moitié de l'humanité à
la prochaine pandémie mais je vois bien
ce que vous pensez vous êtes en train de
vous dire melon la grippe ça donne la
fièvre et puis ça repart d'amis fiez pas
du tout la grippe saisonnière par
exemple celle que vous attraper en
automne ben ça tue entre 250 milles et
500 mille personnes chaque année en ile
de france dans le monde attend donc
quand même quand même alors bon c'était
pas loin donc ça touche surtout sa
touche surtout les personnes fragiles
donc les personnes et les bébés les
personnes âgées ou les personnes
immunodéprimées dont le système
immunitaire ne fonctionne pas très bien
donc là vous allez me dire ben moi je
suis pas une personne fragile m'en fiche
fait pas trop les malins quand même
parce qu'il ya d'autres virus les
grippes pandémiques qui celle-là vont
plutôt être mortelle pour des jeunes en
forme dont le système immunitaire va
très bien j'en vois qui se disent que la
roue tourne alors la grippe pandémique
il ya un exemple par exemple en 2009 le
virus h1n1 qui avait tué à l'époque que
18000 personnes dans le monde mais on a
eu de la chance ça aurait pu être bien
pire par exemple la grippe espagnole en
elle avait tué entre 40 et 100 millions
de personnes
c'est une autre échelle alors bon là
aussi vous allez me dire non mais
attends en 1918 il avait peut-être
d'autres préoccupations que la grippe
certes
tu l'as dit nous aussi on a d'autres
préoccupations que la grèce je dis ça je
dis rien alors aujourd'hui on a aussi
des traitements qu'on peut donner aux
personnes infectées mais ils sont pas
très efficaces
du moins pas assez efficace pour qu'on
puisse dire qu'on sait guérir la grippe
on a aussi des vaccins ce qu'on vous
propose tous les ans en automne mais là
aussi il ya un mais ces vaccins
protègent contre trois virus dont on
prédit que ce sont les plus susceptibles
de vous infecter cet automne mais si on
se plante et qu'un nouveau virus arrive
là vous avez beau être vaccinés vous
êtes malade quand même et si ce nouveau
virus qui arrive est une grippe
pandémique donc la très dangereuse
ben on peut mettre au point un vaccin
spécifiquement pour cette grippe
pandémique comme on l'a fait en 2009
qui parmi vous c'est thé vaccinés en
2009 contre le virus h1n1 ou au moins
une dizaine donc ok à la prochaine
pandémie 90% blanc fille est infecté et
on n'a pas de traitement pour eux voilà
donc là vous devez vous dire mais que
font les chercheurs pourquoi il trouve
pas un traitement qui fonctionne ou un
vaccin universel d'un on essaye mais
pour l'instant on est comme qui dirait
face à nos limites
je suis dans le pen et on va tous mourir
parc enfin voilà
donc là j'ai mis une bonne ambiance
là normalement c'est le moment où vous
avez besoin que j'enchaîne sur un truc
positif
donc rassurez vous parce que pendant ma
thèse avec les chercheurs avec qui je
travaille et on a mis au point un
nouveau traitement innovant qui marche
contre tous les virus de la grippe et
dont on espère qu'il sera bientôt mis
sur le marché
c'est pas vrai pas du tout alors si le
fait qu'on va tous mourir ça c'est vrai
mais le traitement non ça on a on n'a
pas trouvé non ça c'est ce que j'ai dit
aux organisateurs de la conférence un
sexe pour pouvoir vous parler ce soir
parce que je j'avais envie aux lapins
bon bon bah voilà
du coup il me reste 7 minutes vous avez
payez vos places quand même je vais pas
partir comme ça je vais vous raconter ma
vie
du coup on va faire ça tenez par exemple
vous devez vous demander mais cette
jeune chercheuse passionné par ces virus
elle a dû toujours vouloir devenir
chercheuse eh bien pas du tout
figurez-vous que moi depuis toute petite
je rêvais de devenir des terrines r du
coup j'avais fait une prépa j'ai raté le
concours
donc bon après j'ai fait une école
d'ingénieur agronome parce que dans
agronome y'avait animaux d'élevage ou
suis dit que ce serait pas mal
puis j'ai envisagé un peu tous les trucs
qu'on proposait sauf la recherche parce
qu'à l'époque la recherche ça
m'inspirait pas trop et puis en deuxième
année d'école on nous disait ben faut
que tu partes à l'étranger pendant six
mois faire ce que tu veux mais à
l'étranger
alors moi mon deuxième rêve dans la vie
après devenir vétérinaire ça c'était
foutu
c'était d'aller vivre au québec donc
j'ai cherché un stage au québec et j'ai
trouvé un stage de recherche
raté donc bon la recherche lequel avec
la rochelle à québec le québec
donc je suis parti au québec et j'ai
découvert qu'en fait la recherche c'est
trop cool je sais pas si on vous l'a dit
et c'est vraiment sympa à la recherche
donc je suis rentré en france et j'ai
décidé de faire de la recherche
j'ai cherché un stage puis une thèse à
l'inra l'institut national de recherche
agronomique qui travaillent sur des
espèces agronomique et sur leurs
maladies comme la grippe par exemple moi
et j'ai pu faire une thèse en
immunologie
j'étais contente
un détail près c'est qu'en fait quand on
fait une école d'ingénieur agronome
on n'apprend pas l'immunologie en fait
donc je je comprenais rien donc je suis
arrivé dans un labo avec plein de
chercheurs experts de leur domaine qui
me parlait de plein de trucs et je
comprenais rien un peu comme vous savez
quand votre petite nièce commence à vous
expliquer que pour faire évoluer un
pokémon psy il faut utiliser une pierre
lune et vous vous la regardez 11 ans
comprenait rien à moi j'ai fait ça
pendant six mois alors bon évidemment au
bout d'un moment j'ai fini par
comprendre et surtout par parler la
langue des immunologistes et là un
phénomène bizarre c'est quand moi je
parlais à d'autres personnes que ces
personnes ne comprenais plus rien en
gros je devais leur dire des trucs qui
était probablement intéressant et eux
ils devaient comprendre mais tu vois
pour faire évoluer ton pokémon psy
faudrait que tu prennes une pierre lune
donc ça c'était jusqu'à il ya quelques
mois où j'ai participé à un concours de
vulgarisation
donc je devais expliquer ma thèse en 180
secondes
ça fait trois minutes calculait pas et
j'ai je devais faire en sorte qu'elles
soient compréhensibles par tout le monde
et ça a marché
là tout le monde a compris et tout le
monde s'est intéressé à ce que je
faisais et ça ça m'a plu donc depuis je
fais de la vulgarisation à côté de mon
travail
on m'a proposé de faire une conférence
tedx par exemple ça s'est bien passé
et puis ensuite on fait la vulgarisation
avec des amis sur youtube où on explique
le système immunitaire de façon un peu
pointu mais pas trop un peu quand même
et voilà pourquoi je vous raconte ça pas
pour faire de la pub pour ma chaîne
youtube mais parce que ben je vais quand
même là vous raconter ce que j'ai fait
pendant ma thèse
il reste 4 minutes 30 je vais vous
expliquer alors pendant ma thèse on a
travaillé sur une espèce que vous
connaissez sûrement tous souscrit aux
femmes non alors pour les non initiés on
appelle ça le cochon le cochon qui comme
chacun sait est un excellent modèle
biomédicale tant au niveau physiologique
que génétique n'est ce pas ou autrement
dit tout est bon dans le cochon
donc le cochon notamment attrapent la
grippe comme nous et il a les mêmes
symptômes que nous de la fièvre une
perte d'appétit et c'est donc
étudiant plus par bon il peut aussi
attraper les même virus que nous voir
nous les transmettre
donc comprendre comment fonctionne la
grippe chez le cochon ça nous
permettrait de mieux comprendre comment
fonctionne la grippe chez l'homme et
pour comprendre comment fonctionne la
grippe
il faut aussi comprendre comment
fonctionne le système immunitaire qui se
bat contre la grippe
bah ça c'était le sujet de ma thèse
comprendre comment le système
immunitaire du cochon se bat contre la
grippe
alors au début de match on savait quand
même déjà des choses surtout chez la
souris par exemple on savait que dans le
poumon
on a des murs de cellules qui ressemble
à ça des épithélium qui protège
l'intérieur du corps de l'air extérieur
quand la grippe rentrer dans le poumon
elle infecte les cellules de ce mur et
elle les tue ça fait des trous ça
fragilise le poumon et si le système
immunitaire est en forme c'est pas un
problème parce qu'il va réparer ces
trous et se battre contre la grippe
mais si le système immunitaire est un
peu affaibli comme je vous disais au
début pour la grippe saisonnière
là ça pose problème mais surtout avec
une grippe pandémique vous vous rappelez
la grippe plus dangereuse la salle
grippe va infecter beaucoup de ces
cellules et ont tué beaucoup
du coup sa cellule vont appeler à l'aide
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'inflammation et
la le poumon se transforme un peu en
champ de bataille et les défenses c'est
le système immunitaire
alors il ya par exemple des brancardiers
les macrophages qui vont évacuer les
cellules mortes et calmer les blessés
dont qui calment l'inflammation il ya
aussi des sentinelles les cellules
dendritiques qui elles repèrent le virus
et fonce prévenir l'armée des
lymphocytes pour qu'elle vienne se
battre et surtout chez la souris
on a trouvé des jeunes soldats les
monocytes qui se balade dans le son et
quand ils entendent des appels à l'aide
dans le poumon il débarque pour essayer
d'aider comme ces cellules dendritiques
qui peuvent sauver l'organisme ouais
mais voilà ces jeunes soldats
ils ont jamais connu la guerre et devant
l'horreur du champ de bataille tous les
cadavres et tous ses ennemis bah ils
paniquent et ils appellent eux aussi à
l'aide
donc ça devient un cercle vicieux
puisque ya de plus en plus de soldats
qu'ils appellent de plus en plus à
l'aide qu'ils appellent de plus en plus
de soldats
et c'est le système immunitaire lui même
qui se met à faire des dégâts à
l'organisme
c'est pas le virus qui est dangereux
c'est la réponse immunitaire
donc ça c'est ce qui se passe chez la
souris ça vous fait une belle jambe mais
en fait c'est important parce que chez
la souris on s'est rendu compte que si
on réduisait le nombre de ces jeunes
soldats bas la grippe n'était plus
dangereuse donc ça c'est une idée de
traitement pour éviter que la grippe
soit dangereuse on cible des cellules du
système immunitaire
alors ça c'est sympa ça marche elle a
souri
mais bon la souris vous rappelle c'est
gros comme ça et surtout petit détail
qui a son importance quand on travaille
sur la grippe
elle sourit n'attrape pas la grippe en
fait voilà c'est bête hein mais faut y
penser
la souris il faut l'infecté avec des
virus spécialement adaptés et même là
elle n'a pas les mêmes symptômes que
nous donc ce traitement c'est bien joli
mais voilà est-ce que ça marche
qu'est-ce que ça marcherait chez nous
donc la question à se poser c'est est-ce
que ça marcherait chez une espèce qui
elles attrapent la grippe et réagit
comme nous comme le cochon donc c'est ce
que j'ai fait pendant ma thèse j'ai
essayé d'identifier toutes ces cellules
dans le poumon du cochon et notamment
j'ai identifié ces jeunes soldats qui
existent aussi chez le cochon et qui ont
l'air de là aussi participé à
l'inflammation donc visiblement on a
trouvé une cible thérapeutique
potentielle pour se battre contre la
grippe chez une espèce qui attrapent la
gueule et c'est gagné
non mais on a bien avancé quand même
parce que maintenant qu'on connaît
toutes ses cellules
on va pouvoir mieux comprendre la grippe
déjà mais aussi d'autres maladies
respiratoires chez le cochon mais par
extension aussi chez l'homme et surtout
ce principe dont je viens de vous parler
de ne pas forcément ciblé le méchant
mais de plutôt essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe dans le système immunitaire
et de le régler ça ça s'appelle les
immunothérapies et c'est un peu les
traitements du futur en fait en ce
moment c'est en train d'être développé
contre plein de maladies comme les
allergies mais surtout contre plein type
de cancer donc retenez ça en partant ce
soir à l'avenir avec les traitements du
futur on essaiera plus forcément de tuer
le méchant qui vous attaquent on
essaiera plutôt de comprendre ce qui
cloche chez nous et de le corriger
c'est une super de métaphore politique
vous trouvez pas
non je vois là on sort un peu du de mes
compétences de chercheur en immunologie
et de dre sospoker j'ai fini
[Applaudissements]